This video is made possible by VIN sero, watches, luxury handcrafted watches,
but at fair prices, you can check them out at VIN,
Sarah watches.com forward slash biographics more on them in a bit.
Yes.
The fifth century BC represented the pinnacle of cultural,
political and economic power for the city state of Athens.
It was a true golden age that would go on to have tremendous influence,
not only on the Greek world, but on all of Western civilization.
Socrates was laying down the foundations of Western philosophy,
aided by students, such as Plato,
as well as other prominent thinkers of that time in the answer Fenian dead,
who was the envy of the Greek world. Thanks to the talented playwrights,
such as you remedies a man named piteous cemented his position as the best
sculptor in his time when he made the statue of Zeus at Olympia ranked among the
seven wonders of the ancient world.
Not to mention the fact that almost all of the structures located on the
Acropolis most famously the pansy and were also built during this time.
Other Athenians thought that history was important enough to be recorded for
future generations. Here,
we need an old friends of biographics who rolled it to us as well as through
cities and Xenophon.
The architect epidermis of Miletus was considered one of the founders of urban
planning while Hippocrates,
pioneered Western medicine and gave his name to the Hippocratic oath.
All of these great people lived and worked in one place at one
time. And then of course there was Paris, please.
Sometimes the golden age of Athens is also called the age of paraklete because
he was there to support and oversee it all. He was the city's leading statesmen,
a skilled general,
a patron of the arts and an operator without peers under his leadership,
Athens flourished almost unlike any other city in history. It is no surprise.
Then the paraklete became known as the first citizen of Athens.
Eric Lees was born circa 495 BC in Athens. Of course,
his father was a wealthy politician named Zen [inaudible] while his mother was
named asterisk risk day and came from one of the oldest,
most influential families in the city, according to Plutarch,
who will serve as one of our primary ancient sources. Yeah,
a few days before [inaudible] was born,
his mother had a dream that she would give birth to a lion. Afterwards.
The historian goes on to specify that even though Paris Glazer's personal
appearance was unimpeachable,
the Athenian apparently had quite a large and elongated heads. And for this,
he was often the butt of the jokes of Greek poets.
Plutarch's says that parrot leaders had looked like a squirrel,
also known as a CNN onion and that he was sometimes called as the squeal hat,
besides the unusual shape of his cranium.
It was also said the paraklete is greatly resembled in appearance.
A man named Peiser strata.
So format tyrants of Athens who was not remembered fondly in his time,
therefore as a youth paraklete is,
did not enjoy speaking in public and instead focused on his military career,
as he believed that it would be as big as calling it wasn't until he got a bit
older, that it became more eager to enter the world of politics,
given his family's high status,
it comes as no surprise that young paraklete has benefited from a good
education. Some of his known teachers included PIF.
The client is who taught him music Xeno,
who taught him on the natural world and his most beloved to you to an exact her
as who taught him about philosophy,
despite his privileged childhood paraklete you saw firsthand how fleeting power
can be when he was around 10,
his family status was almost wiped out when his father [inaudible] was
ostracized back then ostracism didn't just mean that he got left out of the
Athenian politics.
This was an official procedure that resulted in a 10 year exile from the city.
However, in this case,
it only lasted a few years until the Persians invaded Greece. Again,
as one of Athens's most capable military leaders and flippers was recalled in
defense of the city.
He acquitted himself very well when he led the Athenian Navy in the battle of
Mike Hall and 479 BC.
It was a decisive victory for the Greeks and with another triumph at black Taher
and marks at the end of the second,
the Persian invasion is that a tip has only lived for a few more years after
that,
but he died a hero of Athens and ensured that his son would be welcomed into the
city's political world with open arms.
[Inaudible].
Before we get into the details of how [inaudible] Rose to power,
we should try to get some backgrounds on the reeling political classes in
Athens.
There are basically two groups that we need to discuss the [inaudible] and the
strata guy.
They all cones where the chief magistrates of Athens and other Greek cities.
And they had been around for hundreds of years before the age of Paris Lees.
Basically whenever Athens was not ruled by a King or a tire,
and it was ruled by these icons who usually came in three,
the eponymous arc on the parlor, Mark and the arc on base ileus.
The lengths of their office terms vary greatly,
depending on the exact time period, we're talking about a first,
they ruled for life. Then they were limited to 10 years, and finally,
they were restricted to a single year with the emergence of democracy,
the power and influence of the icons diminished greatly. In fact,
by the time of paraklete,
the office of arc-on was mainly ceremonial with just a few minor civic
responsibilities. The authority was now in the hands of the strata guy,
generally speaking, uh, strata gossip simply means a military leader,
sort of the ancient Greek version of a general. However, in fifth century,
Athens,
that was a board always consisting of 10 strata guy who were in charge of
all the important duties of the city.
While other positions like that of argon were assigned by drawing lots.
The strata guy elected every year,
all strata guy were technically of equal rankings, made decisions through vote.
However, as you might expect,
some were considerably more influential than the rest and their opinion carries.
There's a lot more weight.
Let's get back to Paris, please. Hands in the political world of Athens.
When he was in his early twenties, the earliest recorded act of his,
his data to four and 72 BC.
When he sponsored a play by [inaudible] called the Persians. In this case,
[inaudible] was a Korogocho so rich citizen of Athens who paid for the
production of a play, whether he wanted to or not,
these roles were usually assigned. And in fact,
represented one of the few duties still performed by the Arcons.
But in this case,
it is believed para glees wanted to sponsor this particular play in order to
send a message. Like we said, even though all stranded guy were equal in rank,
some were more equal than others. At this time,
the leadership of Athens was divided between two factions.
One led by them historically is the other by SIM on the plays sponsored by
[inaudible]. The battle of Salem is where the Greeks led by them.
Stokley's defeated.
The Persians people regarded this as paraklete was officially siding with him in
his power struggle against Simone. Unfortunately,
if apparently is he chose poorly.
The list of enemies for [inaudible] was growing larger and larger.
And it included all of spotter who were very friendly with Simone eventually
after multiple accusations, then Mr. CLIs was ostracized and exiles.
That wasn't enough for Sparta though, which accused the former war hero,
aiding a Spartan conspiracy plot and wanted him try to buy all the Greek cities,
not just Athens, since this likely meant a death sentence,
that must darkly was forced to leave the whole of Greece and of all places he
ended up in Persia, which was now led by King asters axes. The first,
the son of the man that the mystically is defeated in battle.
So fortunately for him, the King was not interested in revenge of anything.
He was happy to have one of his father's most capable foes in his service,
the exiled Greek relocated to the prosperous city of magnesia,
where he was named governor and where he spent the rest of his days back in
Athens paraclese was steadily growing in power and winning over the people.
However,
he still had a major obstacle in the form of SIM on like a pair of Oakleys.
He was the son of a beloved war hero. In this case, it was Milt.
Yardi is the man who led Greece to victory at the battle of marathon. However,
someone was also himself,
a distinguished military veteran known for his triumph for the battle of Euro
metal.
He was also richer than America and could afford to be more generous in his
spending in order to win the affections of the public.
It seems like someone had the clear advantage, but fortunes are often fleeting.
All pricklies had to do was wait for the opportune moment to strike against his
opponent and destroy his public standing.
He first acted on some rumors that someone had taken bribes from Alexander.
The first of Mastodon, no, that's not the famous one. And who knows,
maybe paraclese even started the rumors himself. Yeah.
The important thing is that they allowed him to formally charge his rival with
bribery. And even though someone was quit, it it's still attacked.
His credibility. That being said Simone's full was ultimately of his own doing.
As we said, he was close to spot up. In fact, he acted as that proxy.
NASSA sort of ambassador and advocated for a close relationship between the two
powerful Greek States in 462 BC spotter experience to halite
rebellion. They had lots being the lower class of Spartan society.
Similar to medieval serfs.
Someone believed that sending soldiers to aid spotter would help cement the bond
between them.
Other leaders were not so eager with the Persians out of the picture.
They saw a spot for what it truly was their main competitor and biggest threat,
even. So Tim on convinced everyone,
and he personally led thousands of troops to spot it. When he arrived, though,
he received a very unpleasant surprise. The Spartans did not want them. In fact,
the last thing they needed was for the HELOCs learn about that Athenian
democracy.
Simone was turned back and touch a return to Athens completely humiliated.
Afterwards. Barclays had no difficulty in getting someone ostracized in 461 BC.
And he was exiled for 10 years with the opposition gone barricades as party.
It was the most powerful political entity in Athens,
but it was not led by Paris, please. Not yet. Anyway,
it was lands by its senior member and a Menzer of paraklete is a man named Def
realities.
He began in acting reforms to restrict the power of Athenian oligarchs and to
expand the democratic privileges of the citizens.
But he didn't get to see his policies in action as he was assassinated that same
yet. Nobody knew who did the deed.
So obviously enemies of [inaudible] accused the Athenian of killing his
Menza to take over his position. Such accusations were considered baseless.
But if talk,
for example said that they were held as if so much venom against one who had a
noble disposition and an ambitious spirit wherein no such Savage and beast,
your feelings can have to reboot.
He also mentioned squashing Aristotle as his source,
that the killer of FLTs was a man named Arysta Deckers.
Tenara who he was, why he did it in time. Aristotle came to learn of him.
We have no idea lost a history,
but the point is this with the leader of the opposition Maxalt and the leader of
his own party dead paraclese was now able to connect Solidated power and become
the most powerful man in Athens, a position that he would meet until his death.
Now, just before we continue with the rest of today's video,
do you want to take a quick moment to tell you about our fantastic sponsor?
Then Sarah has been Sarah create exceptionally crafted timepieces, uh,
fair prices, these watches they're great looking pieces.
That's certainly not mentalist and taking it off now.
So you can have a look at it.
They have a bowls and distinct look.
This is their take on the pilot watch. It's an altitude watch.
It's got this nice red second hand. Yeah. Nice big face,
very easily readable, uh, numbers. And also, so it's got dual time.
So you can set it to two time zones, which is fantastic.
Got another one over here. This is zero,
which is a bit more of a traditional looking watch has got this great clasp
strap. You just pop that on the wrist, just like that. And it looks fantastic.
These are watches that people will notice that compliment you on. Like I say,
a couple of them actually got a third one, which I don't have with me right now,
but it's also great looking with over 18,005 star reviews. Well,
it's hard to go wrong. The attention to you.
He tells great the price of what you get is great. And the feeling is great.
It's great feeling watch. And like I say, they're not eminently forgettable,
minimalist watches. They've really got a lot going on. It looks good.
Please do check out the full range of Inserra watches.com forward slash
biographics use the goad biographics on checkout and you'll get these special
discounts and let's get back to today's.
[Inaudible].
When Porsche first began its invasion of the Greek cities at the start of the
fifth century,
BC Sparta was the unofficial that's uncontested leader of the Greek forces.
After Sparta came its close allies who were part of the Peloponnesian league,
a group of city States all located in or around the Peloponnese peninsula.
These included Corinth, alias, pilots, and others. Finally,
there were the rest of the Greek States that would probably not have been allies
if they were not fighting a common foe. The Persians,
these last States came to resent spotter mainly due to two factors.
For starters,
Naval warfare ended up becoming a very important factor in the Wars.
Sparta did not have a strong Navy, not as powerful as Athens, for instance,
or Argus or Carlos or kiosk.
Therefore these Naval powers weren't happy that their status in the Alliance
didn't quite match up to the contribution that they were bringing to the war.
Even more contentious though, was the idea of a Greek counter attack.
After the victories at Mike Allen plus Taya,
the invasion of mainland Greece was over and as far as Sparta was concerned,
so it was the war. The Greeks won the Persians left job done,
but other city States like Athens wanted to keep the pressure on and go into
Asia minor and liberate the Ionian Greek States,
which were still under Persian control and have been for almost a hundred years
since they were conquered by Cyrus. The great at this point,
Sparta and its ghost allies withdrew from the war and the leadership of the
remaining Greek States was passed onto me. Athens informed turned 78 BC.
They even formed their own association called the DeLeon league.
The name came from the Island of Del Los,
which acted as a neutral meeting point for all of the members and also serves as
the next treasury. Even in ancient times,
historians such as the use of diabetes regarded the counter attack on the
Persian empire is just a pretext to form this league without any opposition.
The main goal was to protect its members from all future enemies.
And although never stated it was clearly intended to counteract spotters
Peloponnesian league.
From this point on Athens as power and influence in the Greek world,
steadily grew to the displeasure of sparked up over the following decades.
The relationship between the two States became tense,
even though it was still outwardly friendly.
One important moments came when Athens rebuilt its walls in secrets under the
direction of [inaudible] spotter insisted that no Greek cities should build
walls under the pretense that they would provide fortifications for a foreign
invader. If they took over the city, of course, what others took this to mean?
Was that Sparta preferred it.
If the rest of the Greek States relied on them for protection, well,
bathrooms didn't listen to Sparta ruins. Not only did they build their walls,
they also declared themselves free of spot unhedged Germany capable of defending
themselves over the years,
the deli and league slowly but surely turned into an unofficial Athenian empire
since its inception.
Each member was expected to provide an annual tribute in the form of either
money or soldiers or weapons with no Wars on the horizon.
Most members chose to pay,
but Athens instead kept touting soldiers to the forces of the DeLeon league.
After a couple of decades,
the bulk of the league's army consisted almost entirely of Athenian soldiers.
So in reality, the other members were basically paying Athens to keep them safe.
This continued under paraklete,
who was eager to keep increasing the hegemony of Athens over the deli and leak.
At one point, he refused to accept any more soldiers or supplies,
his tribute instead, insisting that everyone pay money. The true turning point,
however occurred in 454 BC when [inaudible] moved the treasury of the DeLeon
league from the Island of Del Los to Athens,
he did it under the pretense that the money was safer in Athens, but in reality,
he used it to fund his own building projects. This was bad for them,
but great for us and great for history as a whole because paraclese his most
ambitious construction plan was to rebuild the Acropolis of Athens.
Thanks to him. The city got its marvelous structures.
His spending ways were not always well-received in Athens. In fact,
they often represent the main criticism apparently is by his political opponents
during the four forties, the other political parties started gaining power.
Again, led by a man named [inaudible] is not to be confused with the historian.
The statesman wanted to have [inaudible] ostracized for playing fast and loose
with public funds and for a while, got the Athenian people on his side. However,
in an example of Supreme oratorical skill,
Patrick Lee's managed to win back the public.
He even said that he would pay for the construction from his own pocket.
As long as the inscriptions were dedicated to him alone,
the Magnum entity of his offer was enough to sway the Athenians public spending
continued as before all throughs of diabetes was himself ostracized and exiled,
empirically state empowered.
Ever since.
And started gaining power and influence in the Greek world.
It was only a matter of time before it would collide with Sparta,
which did not want any other city state to rival its strength, the air 460 BC.
So the outbreak of the first Peloponnesian war between Athens and Sparta,
as well as their allies, just for added clarity though,
this is not the same as the more famous conflicts known simply as the
Peloponnesian war, which we'll talk about in a bit,
technically that should have been named the second Peloponnesian war,
but because it was much granted lasted longer and it had much more significant
historical consequences.
It became just known as the Peloponnesian war ignoring the underlying tensions
in the Greek world.
This war ostensibly broke out due to a border dispute between McGarrah and
currents in 460 BC McGarren left the Peloponnesian league and requested to
join the Delian league.
This caused conflict between Athens and Corinth through where the initial
belligerence of the first Peloponnesian war with Sparta only intervening on
occasion paraclese was reluctant to engage in an all-out battle with the
Peloponnese forces because his army was spread far and wide,
still aiding other nations in Asia,
minor in Egypt who were rebelling against the Persians.
He engaged the Corinthians several times and eventually managed to drive them
out of McGarrah. Meanwhile,
Sparta spent the first few years of the war avoiding Athens.
Instead they battled focuses a senior,
an ally who themselves were in conflict with the neighboring state of Doris.
Their goal appeared to be to conquer or submit all the city States and the
region of Bo OTO and unify them under one leadership.
It wasn't until 457 BC that Sparta and Athens finally met in
battle a to Nagra according to [inaudible] the Spartans one,
but the slaughter was great on both sides,
so they could not press on the attack and stamps or retreat, the Athenians,
however, managed to regroup. And just a few months later,
they soundly defeated all the Spartan allies in the area,
putting a stop to spotters plan of consolidating power.
Barclays had the advantage because it went away in 454 BC.
Thanks to the punishments.
Like we previously mentioned a large part of the Athenian army was still
assisting other nations,
trying to escape the subjugation of the Academy at empire,
the Delian league had sent 200 ships to Egypt to help a rebel leader called in
Aras.
The expedition ended in disaster for Athens following the siege of pro sepsis,
as most of their fleet was destroyed while enormous was captured and crucified.
This may have forced a peace treaty between Athens and Persian known as the
peace of Cali as more or less.
It said that Persia would leave the Greek cities in Asia, minor alone,
but Athens had to stay out of North Africa,
the disaster of the Egyptian campaign and serious repercussions for Athens as it
lost its Naval supremacy.
Not only was it threatened by the Peloponnesian league,
but also by Greek cities from the Delian league who wanted to rebel this
culminated in another defeated,
the battle of Caronia in 447 BC against the boat ocean city States that
Athens had previously submitted from this point on paraclese decided mostly to
stay away from mainland Greece affairs and to focus his efforts on the Jian
where Athens was most dominant as a prize appearance,
it was made by SIM on once the main political rival of paraclese has Xcel was
up. So he returned to Athens in 451 BC still on good terms with spotter.
He first negotiated a temporary truce between the two powers,
which eventually culminated in the 30 years of peace of 446 BC of
us ending the first Peloponnesian war.
[Inaudible].
As a name is a 30 years piece.
It did not last three decades and nobody was expecting it to over the next 15
years. Athens and Sparta continued to act aggressively to one another,
but they did it by proxy, by finding cause to attack each other as allies.
The most notable example of this was the sameon war of 440 BC Athens
intervened in a conflict between Samos and Miletus,
even though Samos was a member of the deli and leagues,
the city reportedly asked spot of a help,
the Spartans seriously considered going to war against Athens again,
but backed out when corn's not joining them since they needed the Corinthian
fleet. As the only Naval power of the Peloponnesian league,
strangely the same cities that were involved in the outbreak of the first
Peloponnesian war again played important roles [inaudible] which was once more
in our lives. Sparta had angered Athens by denigrating.
One of its Holy sites in directly is that issued the McGarren decree,
banning the guardian ships merchants from all markets imports of the deli and
league. It was the ancient Athenian version of a trade embargo. Meanwhile,
Nathans also got involved in a dispute between Corinth and one of its colonies
names, cos Syrah. This is today known as Corfu conversantly current,
the secretly aged eight different colony named Potter day,
or with soldiers and weapons and a battle against Athens.
These were all considered to go against the terms of the 30 year peace and in
431 BC the Peloponnesian league led by Spartan gang academics.
The second declared war and Athens, once more,
perfectly as a strategy was to play to his strengths as much as possible.
Athens dominated the waters, Sparta was unmatched on lands.
He knew that the enemy would come to ravage his territories,
but decided to avoid an open battle.
Instead he relocated his people to the safety of Athens itself.
And while the Spartan army was pillaging his farms,
he took his Navy and plundered the Peloponnesian coasts.
Unfortunately we cannot see the panel Polynesian war to its conclusion because
well, neither paraklete in 429 BC, just two years off to the start of the war,
the mighty statesman and half of his family.
What guilds by a plague that ravaged the city of Athens,
the Peloponnesian war lasted for another 25 years and resulted in a definitive
spot and victory, thus bringing an end to the golden age of Athens,
the age of Paris, please. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe also,
please do check it off. Fantastic sponsor in Sarah watches.
They are linked to below and as always, thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].